>> Reggie: AND AS EVERYONE
STANDS UP IN UNISON NOW AS MR.
CURRY BRINGS THE BALL UP ONCE
AGAIN.
>> Brian: ALEC BURKS GUARDING IT
FROM THE START, AND WIGGINS
AGAIN, AND HERE IS CURRY FOR THE
RECORD, AND IT IS GOOD.
THERE IT IS!
STEPHEN CURRY, THE ALL-TIME
THREE-POINT KING OF THE NBA!
THREE-POINTER NUMBER 2,974, THE
MAN WHO CHANGED THE GAME, AND
THE IGNITER OF THE THREE-POINT
REVOLUTION OF THE NBA AND NOW HE
STANDS ALONE AT THE TOP OF THE
THREE-POINT LIST.
>> Reggie: YOU THINK ABOUT IT,
AND THE WAY HE CHANGED THE GAME,
AND IT IS ALMOST LIKE THE WAY
THAT BABE RUTH CHANGED BASEBALL
WITH THE LONG BALL, AND HE HAS
CHANGED THE GAME WITH THE
THREE-POINT BALL, AND HOW ALL 30
TEAMS APPROACHED THE GAME IS
BECAUSE OF NUMBER 30.
AND THIS IS AN ABSOLUTE AWESOME
EXPERIENCE TO BE ABLE TO
WITNESS, TO SEE RAY ALLEN AND
NOW STEPHEN CURRY AND AN
EMOTIONAL HUG HERE WITH HIS
FATHER DELL CURRY.
>> Brian: YOU SAW DELL AND HIS
MOTHER SONIA, AND BOB McKILLIP
HIS HIGH SCHOOL COACH, AND HIS
HEAD COACH AT DAVIDSON AND THE
MAN NEXT TO HIM IS DAVID RILEY
WHO IS THE MAN WHO DRAFTED CURRY
AS A MEMBER OF THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS AND WHAT A MOMENT THIS
MUST BE.
>> Reggie: AND THE DEGREE OF
DIFFICULTY, RIGHT?
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU HAVE
ONE, TWO, THREE GUYS ON HIM, AND
ALEC BURK CLOSING QUICKLY, AND
LONG THREE AS CURRY HOLDS THE
RECORD.
THERE IS SONIA, HIS MOTHER, IN
ATTENDANCE AS WELL.
QUICK RELEASE.
NOTHING BUT THE BOTTOM.
>> Brian: WHAT A MOMENT.
HERE IT COMES.
AN EMBRACE WITH RAY ALLEN.
RAY ALLEN BROKE REGGIE MILLER'S
RECORD ON FEBRUARY 10th, AND NOW
STEPHEN CURRY BREAKS RAY ALLEN'S
RECORD, TUESDAY, DECEMBER 14th,
AT MADISON SQUARE GARDEN A
28-FOOTER, AND STEPHEN CURRY,
THE ALL-TIME THREE-POINT SHOOTER
IN THE NBA.